uh so what about your solo album
obviously you got a single out but yeah
what is
um I got an album that's coming out
um which I've been working on it for
like two years so I ain't put out and so
um my last album was me and Lil Wayne
project so Jesus I forgot about that
yeah
so I ain't put out no album since then
so damn
I'm loaded I'm pretty much loaded right
now explain to me the little Wayne
project because that is not uh I mean
you obviously got your group [__] with
with the guys but then you got a young
boy album and then a little Wayne album
like
how does the Wayne thing happen like is
it just you guys get in and you guys
just are like yo this is crazy our
chemistry's so good we should do
something full or how does it work uh I
think I just you know I build a
relationship with tune for a little
while I'm saying we're good friends we
chop it up I talked to him like every
week damn near you feel me so
it's like
you know we just that's just like big
bro to me you know I'm saying so one day
he just hit me like let's put a project
together right I was like [__] yeah yeah
I can't wait yeah of course whatever you
want to do let's do it
so you know I might send him a record he
sent it back in like 30 minutes yeah
so pretty much like when we was
recording the project I might do a song
and I'm like oh yeah Wayne be hard on
this send it over he'll send it back to
me and then he'll send me one and then
like back and forth type [__] I was
gonna say like uh what's the difference
between doing an album with him and
doing an album with young boy is there a
difference their creative processes or
um
[__] like doing loud young boy I'll be
over at his house for like two weeks
we'll just be chilling there you know
what I'm saying so you guys would be
actually like fully locked in you're
locked in and not leave right so do not
move Wayne I might come to the studio a
couple days or you know what I'm saying
shoot him some stuff through the email
get it back especially doing doing an
album with young boy he was on house
arrest he had just got out of jail right
and I went to his crib and we just
knocked out the album like was this when
he was in was this one in Utah no no
okay he was in um barrels okay okay yeah
yeah that's crazy that I didn't even I
forgot all about the Wayne album yeah
that's a big deal man not a lot of
people have Lil Wayne albums I don't
know if
besides Birdman father like son what is
another little wind collab album I don't
think there is one
like there's the Young Money album oh
yeah that's hard I think it's like just
you and Birdman have one of those nah I
think I think it's only Juelz Santana
but that wasn't that never came out
officially that leaked I can't feel my
face great [__] great [__] yeah shout
out to Dipset